It's been quite a few years since Christopher
Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy came to a close
with the somewhat optimistic introduction
of Joseph Gordon-Levitt as Robin, ready to
fill in for Bruce Wayne as the protector of
Gotham City.
It was a perfect ending to the series, but
some also perceived it as the beginning of
something new, with Gordon-Levitt seeming
like just the kind of guy to carry the franchise
forward into new territory.
"You should use your full name.
I like that name.
Robin."
So why haven't we ever gotten a Robin solo
movie?
Let's take a look at why Joseph Gordon-Levitt
will probably never get to play the Boy Wonder
again.
DCEU divergence
Although we haven't gotten to see any more
of Christopher Nolan's Batman films since
The Dark Knight Rises, the DC Extended Universe
has still forged on without Christian Bale
driving the Batmobile -- or any other elements
of Nolan's trilogy carrying over, for that
matter.
It would be sacrilege for the studio to continue
the Dark Knight's story without the visionary
writer-director's involvement, and it would
be a hard sell for fans, too.
So, Nolan's trilogy exists in his own isolated
three-film bubble.
Warner Bros.' new direction doesn't seem to
be touching it, ultimately re-casting any
characters that may intersect with it.
This means that, while they're rolling full
steam ahead with an interconnected universe
of superheroes who all share a singular continuity,
Joseph Gordon-Levitt's Robin is probably now
considered to be just as untouchable as anything
else Nolan came up with.
Making matters worse, in the current DC Extended
Universe Robin is already gone, as shown in
Dawn of Justice when Bruce Wayne passes by
a display case containing Robin's old suit.
"The whole idea was that there had been loss,
and there had been sacrifice."
So, even if Nolan did eventually give his
blessing to borrow his version of Robin, well,
they've written themselves into a corner with
that already.
Still, Batman has no shortage of Robins floating
around - but there are more problems than
just one Robin being underground.
"Whoa… there are three other Robin's?
"There have been more than that."
"Golly, our chum Batman sure does go through
a sidekick or two."
Nightwing's next
Instead of bringing Robin back to life, it
looks like Warner Bros. is eyeing the sidekick's
OTHER alter ego to get his day in the sun.
In the comics, Nightwing is Robin's new identity
after he realizes being Robin is lame, and
he ditches Batman to pursue his own solo adventures
under the new mantle.
"This is my gig.
If I'd needed you I'd have called."
This decision by Warner Bros. to move forward
on a Nightwing movie unarguably rules out
any Joseph Gordon-Levitt Robin plans.
It's important to maintain the DCEU's continuity,
and to build a new status for Nightwing, a
character with far more A-list potential than
Robin.
Unless Warner Bros. breaks its tradition of
refusing to recycle any of Nolan's old cast
members and retrofit a new character with
the history of an older one, chances are,
Joseph Gordon-Levitt won't be the guy to lead
up this movie either.
Best left alone
Irrespective of the other reasons Joseph Gordon-Levitt's
hypothetical Robin film will never take flight,
there's also the problem of Robin's unpopularity
as a character in general.
Evidence for this is pretty blatant, as the
single time audience members had a say regarding
his inclusion in a Batman story, they chose
to put an end to him.
Yes, really.
In 1988, DC comics asked readers if Jason
Todd, who donned Robin's green and red spandex
at the time, should be taken out or spared,
and fans voted to end his life.
Since then, no one's really been seen clamoring
for more Robin-centric fiction.
And it probably doesn't help that of the many
Batman films in the caped crusader's cinematic
history, the ones that prominently feature
Robin are widely considered the worst of the
bunch.
"It's Batman and Robin, not Robin and Batman
and I'm sick of it."
That probably means the character isn't viable
as a stand-alone centerpiece for any movie,
let alone one with a significant budget.
Actor apathy
The real death-knell for hopes of a beloved
actor playing a role you'd really like to
see them in happens when they personally come
out and say it'd be an inappropriate idea.
"Holy fate worse than ever!"
We've seen people backpedal on comments about
disinterest before, but to call a Robin spin-off
inappropriate and say that The Dark Knight
trilogy ended exactly where it should, well,
it's hard to walk back those kind of comments.
If a Robin movie ever happens, we'll be introduced
to a brand new boy in tights.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!